では 早速テーマに入ります
刺激というものについてなんですが
あの あまり考えてないかもしれませんけど
生きてるということは刺激を受けていることなんです
ですごい単純なことで
単純と言った途端 すごくなんか嫌な顔をするんですね
我々は単純なことを聞く人々ではありませんと
で でも残念なことにも
すべての真理っていうのはすごい単純なんです
だから難しいことを知ろうと思うんだから
もうもうごちゃになっちゃって
泥沼に陥ってもどうにもならなくなっているんですよ
そういうことだから とにかく単純で理解してほしいんです
生きているということは
定義すると 違う言葉に言い換えると刺激を受けているということ
それでちょっと変わって考えてほしいことは
もう皆様方は生きているといえば
人間だけ 我々だけやと思うかもしれませんけど
仏教の場合はちょっと違う立場で見ているんですね
すべての生命 一切の生
一人も残らず まあまあ
生きている生命として見ているんですね
そういうわけで もうすべての神々も
もう誰でも幽霊ももう何でも入ります
動物も魚もなんだかんだで
微生物ももう人間想像するものを何があればすべて入っているんです
それで実際に人間に想像できない生命もいるし
そういうものをなんでも生命ということに入っているんです
そこで この限りのない一切の生命が
一応生命というんだから生きているんですね
だから生きているということは何なのかというと
刺激を受けている それで刺激を受けるためには
我々は 何かチャネルというかね
器官というのは 6つ持っているんです
現代知識ではね  5つと言ってますけど
仏教では 6つと言っているんですね
で まあどういうふうに考えるになったっても構いませんけど
私たち人間の体を見ると6つありますと
それは耳と目と耳と鼻と舌と体そのものと
それから心というか 意識というかね
その 6つなんですね 眼耳鼻舌身意というふうに
この 6つの言葉で表しているんです
そこで目で見るということをする
見るということは大したことではありません
目から刺激を受ける 耳で聞いているということをしますね
聞いているということをしたっても
誰もそんなに聞くということには興味ないんです
聞きたいという興味はまるっきりないんです
ただ耳から刺激を受ける
それで鼻ありますね で
鼻からもういろいろ香りというかね
そういう刺激を受けているんです
これで舌から味ですね
別に味しろという気持ちはないんですよ
ただ刺激を受けている
体で感覚 触れるという感覚がありますが
これは何でしょうかと触れてみる気持ちはないんです
ただ体から刺激あればよろしいと
そこで意識で 頭で 意識っていうのはいろんなものを考えるためのものなんですけど
まあ別に考えたいっていう気持ちはそうはないんですよ
あるのは ただ頭の中でいろいろいろいろ刺激を受けようではないかと
ですから 生命がそういう六つの器官で刺激を受けている
それで舞い上がっちゃって
酔ってしまってもう楽しく生きてるんです
しかし 誰一人も なんだかな
見ようとはしない 聞こうとはしない
味わうともしない 触れてみようとも感じてみようともしない
物事をちゃんと考えてみようともしてないんですよ
ただ刺激を受けて まあだからこそ
世の中 人間にはもう何もわかってないと
人間といったって もうどんな生命も目覚めてないんだと
というふうに  お釈迦様が教えているんですね
ちょっと批判しているんです
人間というのは 生命っていうのは
まあ無知で無明で もう闇に闇の中にいるんだと
この闇を破ろうとは誰もしないんだと
この間 テレビで面白い番組がありまして
皆様も見たとは思いますけど
まあ一回 二回しか見ていないんだけど
それはそれで中止になったかわかりませんだけど
偽グルメというタイトルで
有名な人々に目隠しをしていろいろ食べ物を食べさせてもらう
それで何食べたかと 当たってみなさいと
そこでまあ和田アキ子という素晴らしい
大変な まあ日本で人気のある人もいましたし
なぜその例を出すかというと
やっぱり神様扱いされている人々ですからね
で 目隠しをして この なんていう魚ですかね
透明なフグ フグというフグ刺身ですね
みんなに食べさせるんですね
一人の女の子が口に入れた途端
ものすごくもう嫌だ なんだこりゃと飛び上がったりする
和田アキさんが なんだこの味は
もう何なのか これは と
こんにゃくみたいに で
みんな外れたんですね
とにかく そちらに出た人々はみんなものすごいもう豊かで幸福で
もう日本にいつでも毎日もう最高な贅沢な食べ物を食べて生活している人々なんですね
皆様はフグなんかはもしかすると年に一回でも食べるか食べないかぐらいのことやと思いますけど
まあ私の場合は食べたことはないんですけど
で でもああいう人々はもしかするともう １週間に一回とか
あるいは１ヶ月間に回とかね
それでお腹いっぱい食べてると思いますよ
ほとんどタダで食べてるんだからね
その上 そこで文句まで言うでしょ？あの店の料理よりはあの店のものがいいやとかね
だからそこほど腐るほど食べてる人で
口に入れたって なんだこれ
もんじゃではないかという態度なんですね
そんなもんですよ だからああいう人々ではなくて
これ誰でも問題なんですよ
私はグルメやグルメやもう美味しいものしか食べない
最高品なものしか食べないとかね
言ったっても食べてないんですよ
ただの牛と同じなんです
もう牛に失礼です 牛にはもうものすごい舌が鋭いんですよ
味覚は まあとにかくまあ
パクパクと食ってるだけで
なんて美味しいですかと
生きていてよかったと
日本人でよかったとかよく言うんですよ
日本のお料理はものすごい最高の美味しいとかね
私はけど食べたことはありますかと
食べたことないんですよ
だから何でしょうかと
なんか頭がどうなってるんでしょうかね
私もいろいろ知ってますから
もう日本で生活長いんだから
全く味に鈍感ではないかと
驚くことというのはものすごくたくさんなりましたから
なんでもう食べることというのは
人間は一番好きでやっていることでしょうにね
しかし もう普通の皆様方はね
もう食に食べる量というのは
私の場合はもう三日分というか四日分なんですよ
だからそれぐらい食べているのに
だから私から計算すれば
私はもうまあ五十六ですけど
五十六は計算難しいんだから五十にして計算すると
皆様方は百五十年 あるいは二百年ぐらいの食べ物を食べてるんですよ
しかし味がわからないというのは面白いんです
で なんでそういう例を出したかというと
別に嫌味を言うためではなくて
まあ生命っていうのはそういう風に
このなんでしょうかね
味を見ない その代わりに何か刺激を得て栄養ではないかと
そこでまあふぐ刺身というものは
一人前っていうのは まあ高級レストランの場合はまあ一万円とか
まあそこら辺でしょ それだけ食べるんじゃなくて
また他のものを食べるんだから
まあ一応かなりお金がかかります
で そこでなんか酔って
ああ 自分たちがすごい贅沢しているんだ
もうなんて幸せだというふうな
この麻薬中毒みたいな
酔ってるだけ 完全に何食べてるかわからないんです
だからフグのもどきで毒入れたっても食べちゃうんですよ
味がわからないんだから
だからちょっとごまかせばもう何でも食べさせられます
だからまあ そういう風に私たちはもうこれ食べる場合はもうはっきりしているケースで見る時も同じなんですよ
見てないんですよ 聞く時も同じですよ
聞いてないんです 有名な人
強引にわざと人気を作った
もうもうそうやってこのもう膨らませた人なんか喋る場合はもうじーっと聞いてるようにふりをする
その人も何言ってるかというと
聞いてみたら何も言ってないんですね
時々私もすごくもうもう嫌になっちゃって
もうテレビに出る連中なんか
本当にこの ３０分ぐらい何喋ってるかって聞いてみたことがあるんですよ
何も喋ってない もうただガチャガチャガチャガチャ言うだけで
何も内容も何の意味も何もない
ただキャーキャー言ったり
ああそうですかとかびっくりしたり
いろんなことをしたりする
ただ音を出してますよ
動物の首なんかひもで死にちゃうともうもう泣くでしょ
そんな感じで 試しに客観的に何か一生一度でもいいんだから
テレビとかラジオとか聞いてみてください
で 音というよりは 私は小さなポケットのキャセットあって
そちらのラジオ部分もあって
これをもう長い間使ってないんだから
まあ何か録音するとき必要だからって
もうちょっと昨日動かしてみたんです
で 動かしてみて まあまあヘッドフォンつけて
まあラジオの曲を回して
10 分  15 分ぐらい聞いていたんですけど
しゃべるわ しゃべるわ
しゃべるわ そこで面白いことは
もうこれ FM で音楽なんとかですから
まあよく DJ でももうペラペラペラペラ英語で
もしかするところは英語のチャンネルもありますから
それではないかと でもチャンネル知らなかったしね
また何のことなく日本語で喋るんですね
それで誰かのもう人に電話かけたりとかね
まあそれでもう相手がもう高校生とか普通の学生たちだからね
夜だからね もう英語がわかるわけないでしょうに
その時はものすごいきちんとした日本語で
今君は何代目の問題とか
そういう話したりして
またガチャガチャガチャガチャまた英語になったりとかね
だから私が聞きたいのは
あの英語っていうのは普通日本人わかる
本人はきちんとした英語を喋っていたんですけど
それも何の意味もない英語
ただアメリカ風に発音するだけ
まあ発音もしっかりときちんとアメリカ人のように発音はしている
では何喋ってますかと
何もない キャーキャーワイワイと言ってるだけで
要は日本語で喋って何かというと
それも何の内容もない
ただ音を出しているというぐらいでね
そこで聞く この聞く人々に売れてるんだから
出してますから まあ分喋って何か歌か音楽一つ流すと
あの分もただみんな聞くだけでいいやということなんですよ
英語ばっかりだから 誰がわかるもんですかね
そんなのは わかりますかね
皆様方 ペラペラペラペラ言っただけで実際に知ってほしいという場合は
NHK なんかの場合は必ずもう通訳入れるか
あのテロップでタイトル日本訳入れるかとはしますよ
だってわからないんだから
ということで やっぱりあの
なんで聞いてほしくないんです
聞く内容ないんですね
ただああかっこいい ああかっこいい
それだけ 何々さんですよ
今日 DJ やってるのはとかね
だから聞いてないというかね
ただ刺激を受けているだけ
それでみんなこれが素晴らしい絵です
あれが素晴らしい絵ですとか言ったっても
もういい加減もうもう捨てた方がいいんで
その意見なんかは 見ていますかと
画家が有名だったら もうもう画家が何かやっていると
間違って手に付いた絵の具なんかどこかにもうもうもうもう吹いてしまっただけで
それでも絵にしちゃうんだから
オーストラリアのどこかで
この猿かゾウかわからないんだけど
筆を鼻につけてあげて
そしたらもういろいろごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃもう塗っちゃうというか
塗れちゃうんでね 自動的に
すごい絵だと売ってるんです
ああいうものでもピカソが描いたと言っちゃうと
これはもうもう軽々く 1千
2千万円になりますよ
実際は描いたのは猿ですよと
そんなレベルなんですよ
世界の人間というのは
だからそこら辺ちょっと研究してほしいということなんです
本当に我々は知識人ですか？と
本当に物事を知っているんですかと
本当にものの味を知っているんですかと
本当に人の話 声を聞いているんですかと
だから自分だけの世界で酔って
ごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ考えながら生きているだけなんです
で 例えば生まれつき障害があって生まれた人を仮定しますよ
そういう人いて ベッドにベッドから出たことがないと
あまりも障害が重度で
そういう人でも結構楽しくいるんですよ
なぜかというと 自分に返ってくる刺激で酔って
生活しているんですね
ですから 刺激中毒っていうのは
まあ世界中の人間というよりも
すべての生命にある病気なんです
刺激依存症 依存症ですね
それは一切の生命にある大変な病気です
刺激なしには生きていられません
例えば こういうふうな話にしたっても
じりじりと論理的にこれでこれ
これでこれ これでこれと説明すると
時間もすごい短く済みますよ
私の頭もきちんと整理しますよ
その場合は でも一つはない
刺激はない そうすると誰も聞いてくれません
大事な話をするときでも
いっぱい刺激を与えなくちゃいけない
それでも話を聞いてくれるんだったらいいんだけど
そうすると刺激しか聞いてないんですね
私の話にしたって 私は誰かを貶したこととかね
誰かを批判したことやらね
何かきつい言葉を言った
それだけ覚えて帰るんです
私にはそんなことを言う
全く興味も気持ちも何もないんです
ただ 大事なブッダの話の中に
ちょっとちょっとあっちこっちでスパイス入れておくだけなんです
それだけ持って帰っちゃうんです
だから仏教って何なのかって
今聞いたってわからないと思いますよ
皆様 長い間話を聞いている方々の方が多いんだから
今日初めて参加なさっている方々がいるんだったら
試しに聞いてみてください
仏教って何でしょうかね？どういうものかと
全然知らないと思いますよ
だから話は聞いてないというか
刺激だけ受けて で 帰ろうと
それは何にもならない
ただ生きただけなんですよ
ただ単に １時間  ２時間ぐらい生きていた
それで終わり  そこはまあ刺激ということの
世界はそういうものなんですね
故に我々は何を言いたいんですかというと
生命は何も知らない 何が起きてるんでしょうかっていうことには気づかない
自分は何者かとも気づかない
暗闇の中に 光のもう兆しも何もない
アンダブートアヤンローコ
アンダブート 目がないんだ
アヤンローコ この世は
世っていうのはすべての生命のこと
まあ書く必要はないと思いますけど
一応 あ アンダブート アンダっていうのは目が見えないということで
ブータっていうのはそういう状態で
目が見えない状態でアヤン
この世はまだあります
ススキは だから一応それだけでいいんです
タヌケッタヴィパッサティ
次の行は見ようとするのはほんのわずかな人間だけですよ
まあ全部覚えてはいるんですけど
まあ書くと難しいというか
時間かかります タヌケッタヴィパッサティサクントージャーラムットーアッポサッガーヤンガッチェディという
まあダンマパダにある例ですけどね
この闇を あのパティッパダはどこかに載せちゃったんです
あ そうですか じゃあそこら辺読んでください
で この闇というか この網を破ってね
出よう 自由になろうということはできないと
私はそのパティッパダに書いたと思いますけど
このカラスの例わざと出したんですよ
カラスというのは鳥の中でかなり凶暴で
頭も良くて鋭くて知恵があるんですよ
結構もうあのカラスのくちばしっていうのはなかなかもう鋭い道具で
で しかし カラスにでもちょっと網をかけてみてください
カラスはビニールの網でも平気で破るんですよ
何のことなく破る 今もゴミ箱なんかにね
網かけてますけど まああれは別に破らなくてもカラスはそれはもう上げて
自分もし食べるものあったらね
食べていく方法を知ってますからね
問題ないんですけど まあもし美味しいものがあって
網のせいで決して取れないと思ったら
あの網も破りますよ あれもうかなりもうきつい包丁でもハサミでもなく切れないんです
すごいビニールのね あれ網だから
カラスなんかある一箇所にもう何回も何回も刺して刺してだから破りますよ
まあ破れると思います
しかし 自分に網をかけられると
もう終わり 何もできん
そんなすごい鋭い網でなくていいんです
そういうことで この何ならもしかすると翼やらそんなものはすごく邪魔になるでしょうね
破れないんですよ その時はもう鳥は何するかというと
この網を破ればいいということを考えないんですよ
とにかく怯えて逃げようとしているんです
逃げをすると さらに翼の中に網が入り込んじゃって
足の中にも入り込んじゃって
もう身動きができなくなっちゃうんです
だから我々はこの刺激の網かかれてるんですよ
だから生命には身動きはできない
自由にならない ですから
刺激だけを受けることを考えていると
それしか知恵がないと
もう網にかかっている
もう網にかかった小さな鳥
スズメみたいなもんですからね
のような生き方なんですよ
やはり仏教はこの網を破れと
この暗闇を破れと言っているところなんですね
自由になりなさい で 現代
この大体まあこの経済的に豊かになればなるほど
このさらにこの刺激 高価なものを追っていく
普通のキャベツじゃなくて
特別栽培した特別分野といって
もう 4倍の値段のキャベツを買うと
しかし キャベツの味が知ってますけど
それは知りません だからもう結構うまく毎日騙されてますよ
今も一つバレてるところだけね
まあ外国のではなくて
国産のニワトリ chicken だと思って
輸入 chicken のもうもう買わされて食べられて
そんな知ってるんだったら味でわかるでしょうに
そんなのわかりません
ラベルさえ変えて変えてあげればね
誰かのあのフランス料理のシェフさんが
この何か日本にあるこの小麦粉を何とか何とか合わせて
フランスのあの何かキノコありますね
大変なこの人気のあるトリュフという
それのもどきを作っちゃったんです
そこで食べてみなさいよ
誰にもバレないんです
トリュフではキノコでしょうに
こんな小麦粉やらいろんなものを
ごく普通の当たり前のものを合わせて作っちゃったんだ
だからトリュフの味知らないと思いますよ
ただ これは高いもんだとかね
見つかるの難しい 難しいんだとかね
フランスのある地方でしか取れませんよとかね
そういう余計な もう妄想というか
見えというか もうあまりにも馬鹿馬鹿らしいんです
結局はこのもう知恵の利いたことをやっているんだということになればなるほど
子供もやらないほど馬鹿なことをやっているんです
そんなもんですよ だから贅沢になればなるほど
もうカバンはこういうブランドでなければいけませんとかね
もうシャツなんかはなんとかのブランドでなければいけませんとかね
そこでフランス製のイタリア製のシャツなんか着るでしょ？決して台湾製は着たくないでしょ
中国製は でも結局は何着てるんですかね
イタリア製だと思ってたけど
どこで作ってるんですかね
それも考えたら これはイタリアのなんとかのシャツを言ったって
まあそこら辺のものすごい小さなところで
もう汚いところで 人々は中国人たちが一生懸命作ってるもんですよ
偽物のことを言ってるわけじゃないんですよ
正真正銘の本物のこと言ってます
全部そういうところに頼んで作ってもらうんです
だからなんですよ そこら辺で偽物いっぱい出てくるのは
だって毎日作っているものだから
同じものを自分でも作って
同じハンコを押して売ったってもいいんじゃないかと
だから値段は下げてますから
いくらかあれほどは神経は使わない
それだけのことをあれほど偽物を作れる人々にバレないように作るということは
いとも簡単でしょうに
だから専門家にもバレないように作ろうと思っちゃうと
値札が上がるんですよ
まあだからまあ少々もうどこら辺でどこら辺で
例えばミシン目はまあこの幅とかね
まあそれちょっと変えるとかね
してるだけで まあそういう話
だからまあそんなあまり関係ない話ですけど
言いたいのはこういうこと
私たちは豊かになればなるほど
この刺激の海に溺れて溺れているんであって
なんかどんどん損しているんであります
ちゃんと味が知ってるんだったら
もう外国のものは味が悪いと
日本のものは味がいいというならば
目隠ししてもはっきりと区別できるはずなんですよ
私もただペラペラ喋るんで
たまに試したことはありますよ
同じものを外国のものと輸入ものとかね
味が変わるものもあるし
全然変わらないものもあるし
その場合 私だったら目隠ししても言えると思います
それでまあ私たちはどんな服
どんな色 どんなデザインとかね
そんなものばっかり追っているだけ
音楽を追っている いろんなもう映画を見だっても
中身ではなくて どんな俳優さんがどんな女優さんが出てくるかということで
それであまり知られないと
わざと商売やってる人々はすぐ人気作ってあげるんです
強引に 強引に人気作っちゃうと
みんなわーっと行って見てみると
日本はベッカムフィーバーになったということと同じなんです
何者かと最初は知らなかったんですよ
それでもう作ってあげたんです
一つのすごいイメージを
それでおばさんたちまでみんなベッカムって大好きで
旦那より大好きですよとかね
ということになるんですよ
別にその人を見て調べて付き合ってみて
立派な人間だとかということではありませんね
ただこの刺激だけで それで新聞雑誌で彼の顔がページで出てくると
もう簡単に売れるというふうにね
で そのように私たちはなんか騙されてるんですよ
世の中は成長すると言ったっても
結局あらゆる刺激が増えるだけ
刺激が増えて これが便利で
便利ですよとすぐ言ってしまう
本当は便利じゃない いろんな新しいものが出てきて
出てきて 出てきて どんどん不便になっているんですよ
生きることは でも便利だと思っている
よく今の現在 我々の生き方を見ると
ものすごい不便なんですよ
東京の辺りだったら 好き勝手に家も自分の土地かもしれませんけど
好き勝手に家さえも建てられませんし
何一つもできない ゴミの処分にしたっても
どれほど不便やというと
我々にとってもかなり問題で
不便な問題であって ゴミ処分する東京都にしたっても
ものすごい頭の痛い問題であって
捨てる場所はないし 燃やしてはいけないものばっかしで
もうものすごいお金がかかるし
収入はないし それでもバンバンこちらはゴミ出すし
ゴミ出すとこでもちゃんと分別しなさい
あれしなさい これしなさい
資源回収しなさい あれこれ言うんですけどね
そこでリサイクルする人々にとっても
そんなのはリサイクルに何にもならんものっていうのはいっぱいありましてね
どちらでもものすごく苦労していますよ
ガラスやら瓶缶のリサイクルしたっても
それなりのものは整理そろってないとリサイクルできないんですよ
ガラスにしたっても 色がついているガラスと色がないガラスというのは全く別だから
これ一緒に粉にして溶かしちゃうと
もうろくなものできないんですよ
だからガラスのリサイクルの人が緑色
青い色 あれあれとか分けてちゃうと
もうできるんですかね
何トンのガラス瓶もいっぺんに潰して粉にしてリサイクルするしかないんだから
方法っていうのは だからリサイクルする側もだから文句言って何とかして逃げようと考えている
東京都もできればゴミ処分をしないで逃げたいんでしょうし
私たち個人個人でも そのままゴミをいっぺんに一つのビニール袋に入れて捨てたい気持ちでいるし
生ゴミももう電気製品も何でも一つの袋に入れて捨てることができれば
ものすごい楽で便利なんですけど
いらんものは家にあるものは全部
例えばベッドやらソファやら
そういうものにしたっても
1年2年使っちゃうと
かなり家具もね 疲れてしまうし
またもっと安い値段でもっと新しいデザインのいいものを売ってるし
そうすると これはそのまま玄関のゴミ箱にボーンと捨てて
新しいものを買っちゃおうという方が便利で楽で気持ちいいんですけど
そううまくいかないでしょうね
冷蔵庫やテレビでもね
一番最新のものっていうのは結構面白くて
もう想像できんほどのいろんなものも入ってあって
買いたい気持ちはあるかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり 15年前から買ってみているものを見るしか方法ないんですよ
処分できんだからね だから結局不便になっているんですよ
見てみると現世は毎日不便になっていくんですよ
でもしかし 我々は口で何言ってますかね
なんて便利な世界ですかと
なんて最新的な IT のあれやこれやとか入っていて
なんて面白いですかと
そういう風に言ってしまっちゃうんです
だからものすごくうまくまんまと騙されているんですよ
騙されていることにも気づかない
このコンピューターなんか出てきたおかげで
本当は仕事はもっと難しくなっちゃって
時間はとことんなくなる
なくなっちゃうんですよ
しかし 便利やと思う だからそういう風になってしまっているのも
やっぱり一つのこの刺激に酔っているだからなんです
では それはまあ最初のところで
一応その最初のところの部分で
結論としてこういうことを言いたいんですよ
和田アキ子さんの例で見ると
一生フグなんか食べてるんですけど
結局は味がわかってないんだから
和田アキ子さんがフグについて何か喋ったってもろくなことじゃないんですよ
別に聞かなくてもいいんですよ
ただ感情がなんとかゴチャゴチャ言うだけで
しっかりと味やら歯触りやらなんとかなんとかわかってないということ
だから言ってることは当てにならない
たとえ経験あると言っても
そこから私は結論を作るんですよ
だから人間がいろんなことについて何言ったってもどうったことないということなんです
次にもう一つ結論があります
私たちは自分で考えるものにはものすごい評価しています
自分考えるものは 私はこういうふうに考えているんだよと
私の見方 私の生き方はこういうものですよと
私があなた言うことを認めませんよと
私はあなたが正しいと思います
私はあなたのファンですよとかね
いろんなことを自分で考えてるでしょ
あんなのはものすごい臭い生ゴミで
何の役にも立ちません
ですから そこは一番気をつけてほしい
私が思うもの 私の見方というものもどうったことない
ただの臭い生ゴミなんです
しかし それ臭い生ゴミだと見ないんだから
どれほど苦しんでいるんですかね
例えば 姑さんがお嫁さんが本当に生活を性格が悪いと
ものすごく怒ったり悩んだり
家庭内暴力をしたりする
この暴力っていうのは手でやることだけではないんですよ
それも人間の変な思考なんです
男の子なんかもうちょっと喧嘩したり
家の窓ガラス割ったりと
それは暴力 暴力 家庭内暴力振るって振ってるんだよと
でもおばあ様たちはよくやってますよ
まあまあ それは置いておいて
とにかく まあこれたった一つの例だけで
姑じゃなくて お嫁さんの性格が悪いんだと
自分がそう思うだけで
それで家庭内暴力いろいろやって
もう家の平和もなくなっちゃって
もう喧嘩になって もう息子も困るわ
お嫁さんも困るわ 姑さんも困るわ
時々お嫁さんが姑さんにご飯をあげないわとか
いろんな問題を起こしちゃうんですよ
起きて まあ大変だ 誰かに相談してみようと
で 相談に行ったところで何言うかというと
もし姑さんが相談に行ったならば
必ずもお嫁さんの悪口バンバンバンバン言うだけで
もしカウンセラーがそんなことを言うのは
それはあなたがそう思ってるだけですよと
人間みんな同じだよと
いいも悪いも言っちゃうとどうなるんですかね
カウンセラーの頭ももしかすると怪我するかもしれません
ですから そういうふうに家庭平和が壊れて
会社の平和調和が壊れてしまって
人間関係がぐちゃぐちゃになっていて
人々は戦い 互いに喧嘩する
戦う 戦争する 殺し合いするということになっているのは
私が思うことが大事にしているんだから
です これは言っただけでうまくいかない
言っても違うよ そんなこと言ったっても
やっぱり私が思ってることは正しいと
それ一番難しいところなんです
ただ 自分がそんなことを思っただけということは
そこで人間には永久に平和がない
人間には永久にもう戦う
争う もう喧嘩する 悩む
苦しむということしか
もう何もないことになっているんです
ですから この和田アキ子さんの味の味覚はね
グルメさんですけど 和田アキ子さんのグルメもどうったことはない
だから その場合はすごいはっきりしたり
はっきりしてるでしょうね
どう見たってもごちそう
もうすごいグルメに食べてる人で
そこら辺の四百五十円のラーメンなんかは絶対食べないと思いますよ
立ち食い屋さんで しかし
そういう人にしたっても
まるっきり味わったことはない食べ物を
ということで考えてみたら
我々は考えるものも同じでどうったことはないと
ただの普通の生ゴミよりもものすごい臭い生ゴミやと
自分の思考さえも 私が思うものは
そういうふうに思ってみると
すぐそちらに平和の世界があるんです
何の戦いもない ものすごい何のストレスもたまらない
大変気楽な穏やかな世界がそのすぐその場で生まれてくるんです
それほど難しいことじゃありません
だから宗教家にしたっても喧嘩するでしょ
宗教争いもあるでしょう
あれはなんでしょうか
自分思うものを正しいと思っているんだからでしょうね
同じ宗教の中でも ものすごい宗派やら派閥がいっぱい出てきて
仏教にもあるし キリスト教にもあるし
イスラム教にもあるし
互いにかなりもう厳しい
何なのかと思う 自分考えてるものはゴミだから捨てちゃえばいいのに
それ捨てないんだから問題なんですね
そこで宗教家にしたっても
自分でも派閥で争っている人が
どうやって一般の人々の家庭の悩みやら苦しみやら解決してあげることできるんですかね
できるわけないと思いますよ
西洋人だったら 自分もプロテスタントに行ったり
カトリック教に行ったりとかね
それでアドバイスつけたりする
それでカトリック教の神父さんのところに行って
あのプロテスタントのすごくいいですと言ったら
それだけで終わりです
追い出されます 何言うんですかと
悪魔の教えではないかと
だから自分さえもそんな調子だから
夫婦に喧嘩するなよと言えないと思いますよ
まあ映画なんかでえらいかっこよくて
まあ演技と言いますけど
あんなのはもう実際世界ではないんだからね
実生活というのは そういう人々と付き合ってみたら
もうどうったことはないんだけどね
聖職という感じはほとんどひとかけらもない
普通の人間です みんな
ですから 普通の人間であることは
破るためには 私が思うものさえも
もうただの臭い生ゴミやと思ったところで
そこで勝利の世界があるんです
平和な世界があるんです
ものすごい穏やかな世界があるんです
そこまでの話の結論というのは
そういうところです で
次に もう一つ新しい 新しくはないんですけど
まあ本当はこの話も前も繰り返しやったんです
このテーマは 全然わからないと思います
騙してます 同じテーマ
この前も同じ教典の同じものを引用して
二回ぐらいやったと思います
だからまあ 私と高橋誠司さんという若い人と一緒に出た後っていうと
もう話あって まあこういう風にしましょうと
けど 聞いている方がすごい新しいテーマやと思うんです
ということは 前の話を聞いてないんです
この前のテーマも同じことでね
リピートです 気がつかない
まあそういうことで まあちょっと一つぐらい新しいアイデアを付け加えないといけませんだからね
まあこれはまああまり騙すつもりはないですから
まあこの今から言うポイントは
木曜日の夜は集めた方々に説明してたポイントなんですけど
どこから始めればいいんでしょうか
この刺激の世界は仏教の専門用語で
カーマチャンダというわけです
カーマチャンダ 読み方はカーマチャンダ
これ覚えといてください
まあ一つ二つぐらいでも仏教の言葉を覚えた方が宝物になります
わからなくても死ぬ時でも思い出してください
お供養しなくても済みます
で カーマっていうのは日本語になってくると欲と訳しますけど
あのー これにはなかなかこの訳できないんですよ
で この場合はね 欲にもカーマというんです
欲 しかし 仏教はもうちょっと厳密にお釈迦様は物事をすごい厳密に見るんだから
別な意味でも使ってるんです
この...お釈迦様はカーマというのはこの刺激の品物なんです
ということは 見えるものはカーマ
見える対象 まあ別な言葉
その時変わったという言葉を使います
そうやってこの音 味 体に触れるもの
それから香り それから概念
頭の中にある そういうものは好きなんですよ
チャンダっていうのは好むということ
まあそこでたまらない
いわゆる見られるものというか
色と形だけですけど それから音
それから香り それから味
それから体の観測 それから頭で考えているいろいろ概念などは
それは好きなんですよ
好きだから離れないんです
ないとすごく寂しいんですよ
例えば音なんか全く聞こえなくなると
もう寂しいというか どんどん怖くなっていくんですよ
見るものも同じで いっぱいものを見られると楽しいんですよ
見るものはどんどん減っていくと
寂しくて寂しくて嫌になって
もううつになってしまうんです
そこで見るものは消えちゃうと怖くてたまらないんですよ
皆様方は真っ暗闇 怖いでしょ
全くも暗くて何も見えない時はえらい怖いんじゃないの？なんでお化けが夜ばっかり出てくるんですかね
夜間夜勤ですかね 呼ばれるのは
昼も仕事をすればいいのに
そういうのは考えないですね
誰に だから私は考えますよ
なんで夜勤ばっかり お化けたち
お化けになったら大変困りますよ
だってずっと夜勤でももうしょうしようがないんです
私はなりないんです なりたくないんです
あれがもう暗闇から出てくる人間の恐怖感なんですよ
暗いところは怖い だからお化けが出るんですよ
出ると言ってるんです
別に食べ物の味も知らない人々いうことは誰が当てにするんですかね
だから言ってること 私は全然当てにはしてないんですけど
まあ暗いところでちょっと音が出たら
ちょっともう何か まあ音です
ほとんど あるいは暗いところでも光は漏れますから
光が漏れて まあいろいろ時々溜まったりすることもあります
皆様 光のこともあまり知らないんだからね
光はもう時々この取って別なところに入れるって置くとか可能ですよ
で すっと消えるものでもないんです
ですから このまあ いろんなこの空気の中で
いろんな分子の中で 特にそれほしいろんなところで光が入っちゃうと止まってしまう
別なところに行けなくてとかね
まあそういうことで 例えばもう太陽がね
まあもう消えてしまっても
日没後でも太陽が出した光があっちこっちもう溜まっているところもあります
ゆっくり消えますけどね
そんなようなことで どこか暗闇のところで
どこかの洞窟で どこかのトンネルで
まあお化けは洞窟 洞窟に出てくるんだってますよと言ったら
昔からいるもんだからいいんだけど
なんでもう最近出てくるトンネルでも住みかにするかと
だからまあ結局環境内だから
みんなそこら辺で恐怖感を感じる
ですから 見るものがなくなっちゃうと怖い
聞くものがなくなっちゃうとえらく怖くなる
で 食べ物の場合は体に栄養を与えることだから
本当は味がない方がかなり健康的なんですよ
味と香りがない方が そうすると純粋に体に必要な栄養だけ取ってもういいやとやめます
食べないと それで体がすごい健康的になるんです
しかし 味がないと我々はえらく困るんですよ
時々怖くなるんです 味の場合でも
例えばリンゴを食べてみましょう
リンゴにはリンゴの香りも味もないと
リンゴですよ これ食べてくれ
食べたところで全然味がしないとえらく怖くなるんですよ
あれ これはとんでもないもの
これは冗談じゃない もうどういうものですか？とかね
これ食べてはいけませんと怖くなるんですよ
そういうことで この私たちは
この目耳鼻というこの ６つの器官に入る情報がなくなるとすごく恐怖感になる
なんで怖くなるかってみんな言ってますよ
私にも何回も誰か何人の方々に言われたことありますよ
なんかすごく恐怖感を感じますけど
どうすればいいんですか？と
それはもう神社に百円出しちゃえば治りますよというふうに単純なものじゃないんだからね
どうすればいいんですか？って言いたくても
そう単純な答えはありませんし
答えはあるんだけどね
それで私ははっきりなんであんた怖いんですか？と
という質問をするんですよ
何に怖いんですか？と
とにかくこの考えさせちゃうんで
一度も生まれてから考えたことないんだからね
とにかく考えさせちゃうんですよ
なんで怖いんですか？なぜ怖いんですか？どういうわけで怖いんですか？と
で 考えさせて それで治る場合もありますしね
時々治りにくいのは もうそんなこと知ってる人なんですよ
あの人のことも この人のことも
あれもこれも怖いんですけど
なぜ怖いか これはなぜと聞いても全然わかりませんと
怖くなるのはバカバカらしいと思ってるんだけど
怖いんだよと だから怖くなることもバカバカらしいと思っている人の場合はもっと治りにくいんですよ
簡単にはね ちゃんとそれなりの訓練ではなくてね
それなりのプロセスを経ない限りは
そこでなんで怖いかという答え今出します
刺激を受けるということは生きることなんですよ
刺激ないってことはどう意味します？刺激を受けることは生きることだから
刺激がないということは生きることはできないってことなんですよ
生きることはできないってことはどんな意味ですかね
生きられないということは
もうこれ以上は死ぬということでしょう
そこは怖いんですよ だから将来のことを考えると不安になりますよと言ったっても
あれは事実じゃないんですよ
本当に自分が自分の死を怖がっているだけなんです
将来病気になったらどうしようかと
体の健康のことは心配で
怖くてたまらないんだよと言っても
それはどうったことはないんですよ
一番下に沈んでいるのは
死にたくないという その恐怖感なんです
それが出てくる それに答えがない
どうせ死ぬんだからね
あんた死にませんよと言ったっても意味がないし
我々仏教徒は死にますよと言う
他の宗教はもっと親切だから死んでも大丈夫やで
永遠の天国があるんだからというしね
私たちは親切じゃないということを覚えておいてください
仏教はあまり親切じゃないんです
厳しいんです ですから死にますよと言うんです
死んだらどうなる？自分で考えなさいと
自分本人の人生だから
私に聞いてもわかるわけないでしょう
だから自分のことを自分でやりなさいと
死ぬのはそんなに怖いんだったら
死んでも大丈夫やというふうな生き方したらどうですかというふうに言うだけのことなんです
まあ死んだっても大丈夫やと
じゃあ生き方すると とにかくこの私たちは暗闇が怖いと言っても
そちらにあるのは死ぬのが怖いということ
お化けが怖いと言っても
お化けに殺された人は一人もいないんですよ
熊に殺された人はいるし
人間に殺された人々はいっぱい見るし
お化けに殺されたということは一度もないんです
しかし 人間よりも熊よりもお化けの方が怖いんでしょうと
熊が襲ってくると逃げるは逃げるは
逃げてなんとか大丈夫やと自慢までするんですよ
熊に襲われたところで
もうよく逃げたんだよとかね
そこで逃げられなくなったところであちこちあったものを
石やら棒やら持って熊を殴ったりして
もうよくうまく逃げましたと言っても
ヒーローの気分で英雄気分でいるんですよ
もう確かに森で熊に出会ったら攻撃されます
それは怖い 熊の方が力がありますから
でもお化けにも熊だったら爪もあるでしょう
鋭い 別に熊は攻撃しなくても
あっち行けということで一つ殴っただけでも
こちらはもう二 三週間の針
もうもう四十ぐらい入れるぐらいの怪我するんですよ
熊はそんなこと考えてなくても
でもお化けなんかは別にそういう爪でちょっとかすり傷でも入れたっていうことは話はないんですけど
やっぱり怖いんですね
それで だからそういうふうになっているのは全くの屁理屈なんですけど
で やっぱり死ぬということが怖いんですよ
お化けは夜が出てくるし
暗いところに出てくるし
人がいないところで出てくるし
どう見たっても刺激がないところなんですよ
もう例えばもうみんなクリスマスパーティーとか誕生パーティーやっているところには出てこないでしょ
とはパチンコ屋さんに出てこないでしょ
ものすごい人間にとっては刺激あるんだから
光はあるわ あの電子の音ね
神経質になるわな キーキーキーという音があるわ
自分でもパチンコをやっていて
それでも見てまた刺激を受けるわ
それでお化けが出てこない
それでどんどん刺激をカットしてカットしていくと
お化けが出るんですね
ド派手なパチンコ屋さんでも全部電気も消して
機械も全部処分されちゃって
ただもう部屋だけ もう雨が漏れるわ
もうもう汚いわ 壁も全部汚れているわと
その時お化けが出るんですね
そこで何かというと刺激が消えたんだから怖くなってくる
その怖さがどこにあるかというと
死ぬのが怖いという死の恐怖感なんですね
死の恐怖感 ですから この人生怖いや自信がないという人々は
ただ自分が死ぬということを怖がっているんだよということ理解してもらって
人間というのは当たり前
誰でも死ぬんだよと 私も死ぬことは死ぬんだよと
まあほんのちょっといるだけではないかというふうに死を観察すると
その病気が治ります 瞬間瞬間
まあ死 死 死を死に近づくだけではないかと
どんどん体が衰えて 食べれば食べるほど体が衰えて
生きれば生きるほど体が衰えて
どんどん死に近づくだけのことやと
まあほんのちょっとの生き方ではないかと
無事万事うまくいって生活したっても
まあせいぜいまあ年 八十年ぐらいのものではないかと
そうやって正しく それが正しい見方なんです
見ると この精神的な病気っていうのは消えてしまうんです
それはやらないでしょうし
やりたくないしね そんな不幸な考え方と思うでしょうに
人が死んだということも失礼でしょうに
他界しましたと言わなくちゃいけないんです
あるいは天に何とか目覚めて
なんでか なんとか言うんでしょ
天国に行かれたなんとかとか
そういうふうに言わなくちゃいけないんですね
死にましたよということさえも
不幸な言葉だと思っていて
もう勘違いももういいところですけどね
まあとにかく それはその死の恐怖感を乗り越えたいければ
死を観察することしか方法はないんですね
それでまた戻ります 私たちは刺激を受けるために
ために この見るもの 聞くもの
味わうもの 嗅ぐもの 体に触れるものと頭の概念などなどがすごく好きなんです
欲しいんです なくてはならないんですよ
なくなっちゃうと怖くなる
不安になる 精神的にイかれてしまう
そういうわけだから 一生懸命
人間の仕事って何なのかというと
この刺激を探す求めることなんです
生きてるっていうことはそれなんです
仕事をしながら あれこれとか
一生懸命朝から晩まで忙しい
忙しい 忙しいとかね そんな仏教の話なんか聞く暇もないんだよとかね
時間は無駄やと この時間に仕事をすればいくらか儲かるぞとかね
そういうふうにまで思って頑張っているのは
結局刺激の獲得なんですよ
それがいくらあっても足らないんですね
その病気にお釈迦様はカーマチャンダというんです
これが我々にある一番第1番目の足かせ
網です これ なかなか破れません
それでお釈迦様がおっしゃっている
この超越した智慧の次元には
足を踏みたければ この網を破らなくちゃいけない
これがもう隅に書かれたもうかけた網なんです
魚にしたっても同じことでしょう
網にかかっちゃうと もうどうにもならん
もう死んでしまうんです
ですから このカーマチャンダっていうのは
この網ですよ これを破ったら
もうすぐそちらにもうブッダ
お釈迦様がおっしゃっているこの超越の世界があるんです
そこで問題は なんで我々にこの網を破れないかと
刺激の網 破れるどころじゃなくて
どんどん網をどんどん強くなってくるんですよ
大体この網っていうのはこの透明になるんですよ
透明になってすごく強くなるんです
あの あの魚釣りなんかやってる時使う糸とかあります
あれは大体見えないでしょうに
見えないんだけど もう破れませんね
すごい力でしょ？もしそんな網をかけてあったら
我々人間でも引っかかっちゃいます
見えませんだから これ動物では鳥なんかつかむ場合は
この研究とかいろんなものにつかむ場合はかなり高い網かけちゃうんですよ
なかなかつかみにくい鳥でも
その網を張っておく 張っておいたら誰にも見えません
人間でもこうやって見ないでこうやって触ってああ見ると
それで鳥たちはまんまと引っかかっちゃう
まあ鳥は引っかかりやすいんです
鳥はもうかなり遠く見て飛ぶんだからね
ここら辺見て飛べませんよ
でも あの網には人間でも引っかかるんですよ
そこで このごっついこのロープなんかでできてる網だったらすぐバレちゃいます
鳥にでも すぐバレます
引っかかりません 逃げちゃう
それで私たちの場合は
どんどん技術が発達と同じく
この網が細くなっていく
同時にすごく強力になっていく
どんどん見えなくなってくる
見えなくなって 網の目もどんどん小さくなる
しかし さらに強力になる
ですから 現代の最新技術で作っている網と同じくなっていっているんですよ
ですから カーマ・チャンダっていうのはどんどん増えて増えて増えて
強化して強化して逃げられないようになってるだけ
ですからですよ お釈迦様の時代ではもう 100人でも 200人でも 500人でもいっぺんに悟るんですよ
今は知識は素晴らしいやと
宇宙のことまで知ってるんだぞとかね
何でも知ってるんだぞと言って
ものすごい頭がいいんだよと言ってはいるんだけど
一人も悟らないんですよ
何かというと どんどん刺激の世界がもう抜けられないほど巧みに強化になって
網にかかっていることさえも知らない
ということなんです 今は全くおいしくないものもすごいおいしいと言って食べてる時代なんです
そこで問題は なんでこのカーマ・チャンダがどんどん強くなるんですか
それにはこの言葉は次に覚えておいてほしい
スバニミッタ スバっていうのはまあ良いという意味で
まあまあ まあ良いという意味なんですね
まあなんて吉とかね 言いますね
大吉 小吉と言ってるあの感じありますね
まあそういうこうなんかすごくいいことです
幸福やと思うことの形容詞ですよ
ニミッタっていうのは対象ですね
いわゆる見えるもの 聞こえるものなど
まあ特色 特性 特色で理解したってもよろしいんです
とにかくもう日本訳はできません
ものすごい苦労して訳はできないわけでもないんですけど
日本ではそういう考え方はないんだから
そもそも ですからできるわけでもないんです
他の言語にも訳することはできません
人間そんなこと考えてないんだから
だからパーリ語でもう覚えておいてください
そういう思考はお釈迦様だけしか持ってない思考だからね
リミットは英語ではアスペックスというふうに訳できますけど
ベネフィシャルアスペックス
それは私の訳で決まってる
訳はまた違います 日本語ではあまりわからない
これが問題だよと まあこれから説明します
で 釣りをやっている時はね
魚とかね 釣りやっている時は
この釣り竿 糸の先に針をつけて
そちらにミミズをつけておく
だから普通のミミズの生き方と違うんですよ
この針の針につけちゃうと
自由でもないし 普通のミミズだったらあっちこっち動くでしょうし
それで針につけてるミミズを水の中に入れちゃうと
このバカな魚たちがパクッと食べちゃうんですよ
食べちゃうともう終わり
もう自由がなくなっちゃう
もう殺されます 誰かに塩を振って
もう焼いて食べられます
だったら魚があんなものはね
口の先でぶら下がってる餌なんか食えなきゃいいでしょうに
自分の目の前で ほらほら
美味しいでしょ？美味しいでしょうと
誘惑されてるでしょうに
ちょっと考えれば 自分の目の前で堂々と動いている虫なんかミミズなんかいるわけないんだと思えばいいのに
そう思わないんですね
すぐ食べちゃう 餌っていうのは勝手に来て
私を食え食えというわけないでしょうに
それ世の中どこで我々にしたっても
食べるってこと 大変な仕事でしょうに
口に食べ物が落ちてくるわけじゃないし
苦労してジャガイモを栽培しなくちゃいけないし
それも苦労して取らなくちゃいけない
取ったっても食べられないし
洗ったり 皮を剥いたり
茹でたり 揚げたり いろんなことをしなくちゃいけない
その上味までつけたりとかね
大変な作業なんですよ
それで家に入ったら もう人は誰もいないのに
堂々と料理なんか用意してあると
これは良かった 恵まれているんだと思って食べちゃうと
もう怖いんですよ これは誰にしても同じことで
魚にしても目の前にぶら下がっている獲物を食べるなよと
それで次にこれ考えてください
しかし 魚にとっては自分の目の前でミミズがいると食べずにいられないんですよ
この習性なんですよ 獲物を見たらすぐ飛んで食べる
でなきゃどうせ逃げられる
そういう習性があるんですよ
飛んでパクッと食べないと
もうナイフとフォーク持ってこうやって見ると
食べるぞと思っちゃうと
もう逃げてるんですよ
だからやられちゃいます
そこはもう魚がバカだからと思っても
全ての生命はそういうふうにやられているんですよ
魚だけじゃないんです
そこで どんな生命にも自分のすぐに見ったのセットがあるんです
こう 例えばミミズを食べる魚がいる
池にジャガイモを入れてみてください
食べないでしょ あるいはきれいだからバラの花ぐらい
つけてずっと待っていてください
いくら何時 何年待っていたっても食べないんですよ
だから 釣りする人々はどんな魚釣るかっていうことによって餌変えるんですよ
餌変えなきゃ自分期待する魚は取れませんね
それはどういう意味するかというと
各生命に自分が弱い情報のセットがあるんです
例えば 猫に気に入られてほしいんだったらニンジンあげてください
猫は付き合ってくれますかね
全然付き合ってくれませんよ
それだったら何かね 干し魚とか干し魚でもほんの軽く焼いてあげてみてください
軽く炙って すごく気に入りますよ
でもニンジンはダメなんですよ
で ウサギさんに仲良くしたいと思って
あ 猫に効きなんだからね
猫はもうちょっと炙った魚はもう抜群に効きますよと
だったらウサギも同じだよと言ってウサギにあげてみてください
どうなるんですかね 効いてくれないでしょう
それでウサギのところに行くと
ニンジンかキャベツか持っていかなくちゃいけない
そのように惹かれる 釣られる情報っていうのは
各生命に自分のセットがあるんです
私たちも人間もまんまとそれに釣られちゃいます
例えば日本の社会の場合は
西洋文化は素晴らしいと
西洋人と同じくなることはすごいかっこいいんだと
もう暗示かけられてるでしょ
どうすれば全く西洋の人々と同じくなるかと
同じくなればなるほど
自分がすごい現代的でかっこよくて進んでいるというふうに思っているんですよ
それでもうもう釣られちゃいます
品物を買う時でも ブランドの名前決める時でも
もう決まって西洋のものでなければいけません
いいものは日本製あっても
やっぱり向こうのということで
例えばカバンなんかは日本でも作ってますけど
買わない 注文して作ることもできますよ
私にはこういうデザインの
そういう形の このようなものが欲しいやと言ったら
もういくらでもいます
技術もなかなかの腕前で
でも買わないんですよ
まあ買う時でも まあ 1万円前後でないと買わない 5
万  10万といったらもう殺されるでしょ
しかし 西洋のブランドだったら
まあ値段が上がれば上がるほど買う
だから そういうふうにどうにもならんで
そんなことを私が言ったっても
どうにもならん もうみんなもうやられちゃいますよ
魚と同じなんです いくら言ってもお金があったら買っちゃいますよ
そこなんですね 問題は
そこは勉強してほしいんですよ
それで子供がいるとしましょう
子供と仲良くしたい その場合は
まあフランス製のカバンかシャツとかあげてみてください
全然相手にしてくれませんよ
これはアメリカ製ですよとか
だから子供を自分でまあ釣ってしまいたければ
この子供に目がないものはあるんですよ
どうにも我慢できないもの
それをあげればいいんですよ
で まあこれは試したことあるものなんですけど
例えば小さな子供がいて
まあお母さんがどこかへ出かける
子供はおばさんのところに預けなくちゃいけない
子供はなかなかおばさんのところに行きたくないというか
夜泊まりたくないとかね
で その場合はまあ向こうは向こうで問題知っている大人だから
その子供はすごく 例えば何でしたっけ
あれ なんとケーキ 子供よく好きなケーキありますね
あのまあスポンジケーキなんですけど
まあショートケーキですか
何でしょう で  おばあちゃんが何のことなく
なんか家で今日なんかすごい美味しいソフトケーキがあったんだけど
まあ帰ってから食べようかなと思ってますけど
そんなとこ別に行っただけで
子供はじゃあ行こうと言うんですよ
じゃあおばあちゃんの家に行くと
今まで行かない もう家にいたいとかね
言っていた子が何のことなくショートケーキあるよと言ったら行っちゃう
メロン好きだったら昨日ね
もうメロンがもらったんで
あれすごい美味しいやと言ったら
もうじゃあ私も行くんだ
もういとも簡単に釣られてしまうんですよ
そうやって でも その子供が二十歳になった時もショートケーキあるんだけどと言ったっても
それでは来ないんですよ
で そこら辺で私たち人間にも
それでまた各人によって違いますよ
ショートケーキ好きな子もいて
メロン好きな子もいる
食べるものよりはゲームに目がない子もいるし
それぞれ人によって餌が違うんです
そうやって年取っていくと
時とじわじわとそれも変わっていくんですよ
だから ２０代の若者がやられる餌と
私のような５０代の人をやる餌っていうのは随分違うんです
ですから おばあちゃんを楽しくさせてあげようと思って
孫がディスコに連れて行ったっても
あれはおばあちゃんにとっては全く面白くもない
まあもうとんでもない世界なんですね
そう だったらまあ巣鴨の駅でも降りる
おばあちゃん 巣鴨でも行きましょうと言ったら
いい子でね 大変親切で優しい子ですよと言いながら仲良く行くんですよ
そういう風にいろんな人にも自分がどうにもならん餌っていうものはあるんです
それは六つなんですよ
全部 ６種類の餌があります
目と耳 鼻 口 体 頭という六つに合うもの
それはそれぞれ時代に応じて
人に応じて変わるんですよ
その餌に気をつけなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから他人よりも自分が知ってるでしょ
自分がどんな餌にやられるかと
どんな餌に釣られるかと
これ他人に知られたら大変ですよ
もううまく奴隷にするんだから
今もそうでしょうに 我々は
人間の場合は簡単に言えばね
まあ猫の前で魚を置いておく
それで猫がもうやられちゃいます
その人ということは 何でも聞くということになります
人間の前でお金をちょっとまいておけば
しかし 猫の前で一万円札をまいたっても
猫は全然気にしない すぐ釣られてしまうんですね
それで奴隷になっちゃうんですね
その人ということは 何でもする
私たちはそのからくりから逃げてるわけじゃないんですよ
いつでもパクパクと餌を食ってるんですよ
だから奴隷で生きてるんですよ
お金くれるんだったら何でもやるという状態で生きているんですよ
あなた言うんだったら人殺しでもするぞと思ってるんですよ
もしそんな状態で生きている
何でもする この刺激依存症の問題はこれなんです
奴隷になってしまう その時はわからないんですよ
例えば若い人々はもう何かにもう凝ってしまって
もう親に逆らうわ 先生に逆らうわ
もう何でもやっちゃう
自分好きな何かに好きと思っちゃうと
こんなのはやってはいけませんよといくら言っても聞かない
例えばオートバイ好きになっちゃうと
もう学校もやめて もうそれやっちゃうんですね
そこでオートバイ買うお金を親が出してくれないと
もう親は殴ったり何でもする
あれはもう家の何でしたっけ？あれは
銀行の 何といいますか
あれは預金証 キャッシュカードか
それでも盗んででも持っていく
持っていってオートバイを買っちゃうと
それで親が心配する そんなバカなことするなよと
あんたまだ歳ももうライセンスも取れないではないかと
学校に行くことではないかと
そんな将来のことどうでもいいんです
その場合は もう見えません
それしか そこで私たち大人は
もう本当にこの子供たちっていうのはバカじゃないかと思っちゃっても
我々も同じことで 私たちは何に釣られているかさっぱりわからない
自分が決めたことでずっと生きていってます
それで怖いということは
死ぬまでそういうふうに獲物に釣られて生活するということ
だからこの獲物ですよ
スヴァニミッタっていうのは
獲物といえば食べるものしか
食べるもので考えちゃいますけど
もう仏教はすべて食べるものにしているんですよ
この目 耳 鼻に入るものは全部生命を維持する栄養である
ですから食べ物なんです
食べるものではなくて栄養要素なんですよ
それがないと生きていられないんだから
ですから 正しく日本語すれば
スヴァニミッタっていうのは獲物って意味なんですよ
でも解釈しないでそれも獲物と言ったりすると
また誤解しちゃうんだからね
普通の日本語だったらね
動物の食べ物をね 獲物というんですから
まあしかし 食べ物とするか栄養要素とかくよりは
獲物という言葉がすごい効き目がいいんです
働きはぴったしです 獲物に釣られるのは馬鹿だから
我々もいろんなこの六
六種類の獲物に釣られて生きているんです
これ 逃げられないっていうのは
二十歳の獲物が二十五歳で変わるんだだから
二十五歳の獲物っていうのは
二十六になってまた変わるでしょうね
だから一向に気づかないんですよ
過去のことには気づきますけど
昔 二十歳頃 えらい馬鹿なことをやっていましたと
今更気づいたってもう遅いし
今どうですか？って言ったら
今は大丈夫やと  OK やと言うでしょ
でも嘘ですよ 今別なものにやられている
これが本当に面白いことなんですね
生命の そこでこの弱みも理解してほしい
魚に干し魚見せちゃうと
もう魚ではない 猫に干し魚見せちゃうと
もうどうにもならないんですよ
もう食べちゃう この間ニュースにあったんだけど
どこかの犬がね 散歩にして何かもうパン食べちゃって
置いてあったパン食べちゃって死んじゃったと
あっちこっち誰かがこの食べ物を置いておいて
全部毒を入れちゃって
それで同じことなんで
飼ってる犬だから餌もらってるでしょうに
それもすごい丁寧に管理して
食べ過ぎにならないように
1日に必要な栄養だけきちんと自分の健康を守って面倒見てくれるんだから
なんで散歩をしている子
捨てている道路の横に置いてる餌食うんですかね
もう行儀が悪いというか
もう出来が悪いでしょうに
しかしどうにもならんで
見たら食べちゃった 食べたところで毒でしたと
もう遅いんですけど そういうことでね
まあその時はわからないんですね
弱いんですよ この弱みある限りは
我々はどんどん束縛されて
どんどん不幸になっていく
ですから このお釈迦様おっしゃったのは
まず自分には獲物のセットがあります
それも日々変わりますよ
あまり変わらないものもありますけどね
しかし変わります 例えば子供の頃はもうジャガイモも大好きですって言っても
死ぬまで好きっていうことはちょっとわからない
変わる可能性はあります
若頃はもう肉しか食わないんだよと言っている人も
まあ年取ってくると もうそれはもう結構やっていうことになる可能性はあります
ですから この変わらない
それほど早く変わらないものもありますし
もうどんどん変わってしまう場合もあります
とにかくまず私たち 誰でもやられている獲物
セットがあるんだよ それはまず理解する
次に なんで食っちゃうんですかね
弱いからでしょ まあ魚の前で
ミミズがもう動いてるんですね
行ったり来たり 行ったり来たり
行ったり来たり まあちょうどいいところでもう食べられるぐらいの距離で
それでパクッと食べてしまっちゃうんで
野生だからね そこで魚には一つはないんで
ちょっと観察能力ないんですよ
こんなのはありきかと
こんな楽に私を食えと
目の前で動いて泳いでいるミミズなんかいるわけないんだよと
そんな虫なんかいるわけないんだと
そのちょっとの観察あれば食わないでしょ
そのちょっとの観察に仏教はヨーニソマニシカラというんです
ヨーニソマニシカラ ヨーニソっていうのはもう正しく
この因果法則にのっとって論理的にということなんです
論理的にしっかりと いわゆる原因がいろいろ
なんでこうなるんでしょうか
なぜこうなるんでしょうかとか
そこら辺はちょっと客観的に
論理的に取って見てみること
マニシカラっていうのは観察することなんです
だから魚でもちょっと考えれば
もう命は守られます そういうことで
このヨーニソマニシカラがない場合は
スバニミッタに引っかかって
どんどんカーマチャンダが増えるんだよと
もう逃げられませんと
ですから ヨーニソマニシカラがあったら
スバニミッタに引っかからないで
カーマチャンダが破れる
まあこうやって論理的に考えるならば
我々は誘惑されている
あらゆる獲物には釣られないんだよと
釣られないとカーマチャンダという闇を破れるんだよと
依存症は破れます そういうことで
原因はたった一つ 私たちはもうバカになっている
原因 苦しんでいる原因
あらゆる混乱の中で生きている原因
どうにもならない状態にいる原因
たったヨーニソマニシカラがない
それだけ ちょっと見ればもううまくいくんですよ
それ一つで全て解決するんだよとお釈迦様はおっしゃっているんです
ヨーニソマニシカラさえあれば
きちんと客観的に物のことを観察しなさいと
人が言うことでは騙してはいけません
例えば 今 宣伝の世界 コマーシャルの世界だから
とにかく騙される 騙される
イメージ強引に作る 人気作ろうと思ってものすごい強引ですよ
携帯電話のストラップに何か入れたり
あれやこれやシール作ってあったり
もう子供たちの場合でもね
もう体に悪いチョコレートやらお菓子やらもう食べさせて病気にさせてあげようという
もう企みですけど それから儲かりますよと
しかし 子供にしたっても
そんなに買いたくはないんだからね
その中に何か得もの入れていくんですよ
何かカードとか それは集まるんで
これはセットありますよと
ゴールドのカードもらったらすごい最高ですよと
しかし ゴールドのカードはまあ 10万枚に 1しか作れませんよとか
そうやって宣伝する そうすると子供たちが買って買って買って
調べて調べて調べて それで会社が儲かる
本当に騙されてるんですよ
必要なものを買わせてもらっているわけじゃないんですね
それで何か得ものつけておる
大人もやられる場合もあります
なんかチョコレートエッグというね
ものがありまして その中に何か小さな何かある入れてるんですね
大人もそれ集まるみたいんですよ
そこで買う時はチョコレート買わなくちゃいけない
で 卵の形にあって それを破って開けたら何か入っていて
それで自分が何か まあ今コレクションにはこれこれないやとわかったら
最初からそれを教えてくれるんですよ
こういうものが 12個ありますよと
それでみんな 12 集まりたくなっちゃうんです
それでチョコレートエッグはもうもう 400個ぐらい買っちゃうんです
せっかく買ったものはもったいないとかで言って食べちゃう
さらに不幸になる そうやってもう騙してる世界なんですね
ですから ちょっと観察能力使えば
まあなんとかうまくいく
でも観察能力使えない
なぜならば すぐ楽しいと思っちゃうんです
こんなゴミを集めたっても
何の役にも立たないということは
やっぱり楽しいということになっちゃう
それでやられちゃいます
もう何でもそうやって人騙す
昔 テレフォンカードシステムができたところで
まあいろいろカードの売買
10万円でも売ってましたよ
もうもうこれは珍しいカードやとか言って
本当は 500円ですけど
そこで手で触るな 触るなよ
触ったら値段がもうなくなるんだよ
だからビニール袋に入れたままで
一回も使わないで  500円のテレフォンカードを10万円でとか
売買やったりして 全く無意味なやられている世界なんですね
そういう風に とにかく商売の世界で
これはただの商売の世界で
人の金を奪うためにやっていることですから
いろんな工夫していて
それだけではなくと あらゆる所で我々人
人間というのは誘惑して騙しているんですね
なぜ騙されるかというと
これ獲物ぶら下がっていると
これ食べたいんですよ
だから猫と魚と全くも変わりない
大差ではなくてね 魚はもう見つめたらしょうがないし
まあそういうカードコレクションやら
いろんな小さな何とかのもののコレクションをやっている人にとっては
それを見るともう楽しくてたまらないんですね
欲しくてたまらないんですよ
だからまあ やられてしまう
そこら辺で観察能力を使ってくださいと
そうするとすべての問題は解決するんだよと
そういう単純なレベルの話ではなくて
仏教で言っているのは
我々は人間 生命として構成しているシステムの問題で
私たちはどうしても目で
目で見ていないで目から喜んじゃう
耳でものを聞かないで
耳から喜びを探している
音は何でもいいんですよ
喜びさえあれば だから音楽といってどんなくだらんくだらない音を作ったっても
相手喜ぶんだったらそれで音楽にするんですね
何でもいいんです 音は何なのかと観察しない
見えるものって何なのかと観察しない
味って何なのかと観察しない
そういうことで あの そこで心の中でちょっと悪いシステムが現れます
少々これからちょっと難しいところに入りますので
ちょっと五分ぐらい休憩いたします
あるならば 誰でも引っかかっている
このまあ刺激の問題 まあちょっと
詳しく話してみます 詳しくといったっても難しいんです
ちょっとこれは書いて書いて見せた方がよろしいんですけど
私は残念なことにこのパーリ語でしか書けないので
ちょっとパーリ語で書きますけど
皆様方は日本語で理解してみてください
1番目 チャックという言葉
これは目ということなんですね
目に入るものは あのパーリ語だったらルーパと言うんです
目にはルーパが入りますと
で だからこれは見えるものと対象ですね
こういう難しい単語を別にこれから気にしなくてもいいんです
まあ自分の言葉でいいんです
目があって 目にいろんなものが見える
目に何が見えるかというと
皆様知ってますか 目に入るものは何ですかね
で 学校では目に入るものは光やと言ってますけど
光は見えません 光は全く見えません
どんな強烈な光でも それを覚えておいてほしいんです
例えば ものすごい強烈な光の光線がこうやって出ていても見えません
それはこの中にほこりとか何とかあると
そこで見えるだけであって
見えるのは色と形です
色と形です 色がないものに光を当てても当てても見えません
例えば空気 見えませんでしょ
空気には色がないんですよ
そこでなんとかして空気に色が色をつけちゃうと見えるんですよ
ということだから 見えるのは色と形
それで十分です それはまとめて仏教でローパというんです
そこでまあ 私たちは一応まあ生きているものだから
目には感覚能力というものがあるんですね
で この 2つがある時はチャックヴィンヤーナというものが起こるんですよ
あ これ間違ってました
じゃあこちらは間違い
ありがとうございます
じゃあこれ水とだから
うん スイカ君だけど チャーというもんです
チャックビンニャー これチャックビンニャーですね
チャックビンニャーっていうのはこの認識ですね
見えたという感じですよ
ただ見えただけで 何か何だかもさっぱりわからない
目に映っただけ 目を開けたらただ目に入るだけ
建物だとわからないよ
花ですよとわからない
ただ目を開けたら もう何とか受け取るんですよ
情報が この情報が受けた瞬間ですね
チャックインがなって
だからこれ日本語では眼識と読むんですが
まあ適当な言葉で理解してください
見えたという瞬間的な感覚
何を見えたかはまだわからない
その状態 そこでこの ３つ
のおかげで この ３つはあるインパクトを作るんですよ
目も見えるものも見えるという
その瞬間的な認識 感覚
まとめてインパクトが作るんですよ
体の中に そのインパクトにカッサというんです
で これは日本語 仏教 日本語では即と書きますから
触る 触れるという即ですけど
あんまり まあまあどうでもいいんですけど
まあ一応インパクト 現代風に言えば
そこで目に何かインパクトが起こるんですよ
このインパクトが起きたら
はっきりと感じてしまうんですよ
これはしっかりと感じてしまう
まだわからない 何を見たかと
そこで体で感じてしまったら
知るということになるんです
この感じたものを このインパクトから感じたものを知るんですよ
外にあるものを知るわけじゃないんです
そこでわざと仏教はこういうふうな文章でそれを言うんですよ
一言で書けばいいんですけど
サンガナクと言って しかし
ヤンゲーゲーティパンサンジャーナーティという文章で言うんです
文章だから主語があるんですよ
突然主語が現れる これでただ目そのもの
目っていうのはただの部品でしょ？見えるものっていうのはただの部品でしょ
そこで感じちゃう それをほんのほんのちょっとのことを感じてしまう
それで体にインパクトが起こるんですよ
インパクトが感じること
感受性 それから あ 私が知ったんだよということになっちゃうんです
この場合は私が見たんだよと
そこで突然私がということが出てくるんです
最初はまあ私がということないんですよ
目が開けた瞬間で ただ映っただけで
私も誰も何のこともない
ほんのちょっと ほんのちょっとの時間で
あ 見えた 見えたと言った瞬間で
私がということは隠れているんです
だからどこもなく いきなりもう私がというのは何の根拠もなく現れるんですよ
このインパクトが ですから
一つの単語で言えば ヴェーダナからサンジャーナということが生まれるんですよ
サンジャーナ サンジャーナ
で サンジャーナというのは知るということなんです
もう知ったと この場合は見たということ
しかし ただサンジャーナ書かないで
こうやって文章をつけておくんです
なぜかというと そこで自我というあの妄想概念がそこで生まれるんです
ちょっと難しくなりましたから
もう一度繰り返します
目を開けたら 色とか形が目にぶつかっちゃう
ぶつかったら何かぶつけたそうとわかるんですよ
何かぶつけたそうだけしかわからない
それがパッサというインパクトなんです
何かぶつけたあと あ それが何かぶつけたんですかと知るんですよ
知るとき あ 見えたよと言うんです
だから面白いことは 例えば目を開けて外の外を見ても
その外のこと見えるんじゃなくて
知るんではなくて この目に起きたインパクトを知るんですよ
だからですよ みんな同じものを見ても
知識はバラバラなのも
例えば一人の人がある一つのものを見て
これが綺麗やと言ったならば
全ての人類はそれを見て綺麗やと言うはずなんですよ
すべての生命 犬も猫も綺麗と言うはずなんですよ
だって品物は同じものだから
ある一つのXという品物があるとしましょう
それがある人間が見る
見て あ これが綺麗なものやと
それだったら すべての人間はXという物体は綺麗ですよと言うはずですけど
そうは言わないんですよ
それで犬猫もそう言わないんですね
だから問題なんです それで見たそのものを見ているんではなくて
目に起きたインパクトを知るんですよ
だから 私のインパクトと他の人のインパクトがそれぞれ違いますから
例えば目が弱い人のインパクトと目がすごい鋭い人のインパクトが違うでしょうに
あるいは目の中の水晶体がほんのちょっと汚れて濁っている人のインパクトと子供の目のインパクトが違うでしょうね
知ってますかね 子供っていうのはなんで単純なことにあれほどしがみついて面白がって遊んでいるんですかね
今は商売の世界で子供を騙しちゃって鈍感にしているだけで
そうでなければ 子供を楽しませてあげることはすごい簡単ですよ
ほんのちょっと色の紙一つあげただけでも
わいわいと楽しいんですよ
これは大事だからもね
目がすごく綺麗で優れているんだ
鋭いんだからインパクトがすごいんですよ
私たちの場合はもうそれほどインパクトは強くない
だから子供はちょっとしたことで喜んだりする
それで頭の悪い大人たちが
あらゆるもうむちゃくちゃいろんなことをして
いろんなおもちゃを作ったりしちゃうと
子供のあの鋭さが鈍感になってしまって
もっと欲しい他のもの
他のもの 他のものともうもうやられちゃいます
釣られちゃいます で 親が困るんですね
いくら買ってあげても足らないんだから
おもちゃあげない子だったら
何かちょっとしたことで一生懸命遊ぶんです
インパクトはそのまま
とにかくだから子供に何か見たら受けるインパクトと
大人の目に何かをするインパクトはそれぞれ違う
だから何か知ったんだそうということが
それぞれ人によって違うんです
というどういうことかというと
本当に何があるかとわからないということだ
だから見てないんですよ
そこはもう心 心ではなくて体の構成なんですよ
これがもうしょうがない
こういう風になってるんです
見られないように目ができているんです
聞こえないように耳ができているんです
我々は聞いてました 見ましたというのは
自分の体に起きたインパクトなんですよ
そこで私がという化け物
幻想 幻覚も起きているんです
次に このサンジャーナ生まれるでしょ
知るということ 次にジャンサンジャーネーでタンビタッキーという次の働きするんですよ
このサンジャーネからビタッカ
ビタッカっていうのは
まあ簡単に言えば考えちゃう
ずっと考えるっていうことではなくて
瞬時にちょっと概念を使って考えちゃう
だからこういうこと 目を閉じていて
瞬時に目を開ける 開けたらインパクトが入っちゃう
入ったらあ 見た あ 花だとか
花と言う瞬間がビタッカなんです
目を開けて 私は窓から外を見て
建物や赤い建物だと言った瞬間でビタッカなんです
考えてるんですか？その時は
皆さん それ全然考えてないやと思ってます
考えてるんです 赤いレンガの建物というためには考えなきゃいけないんですよ
これ微妙なことを仏教で考えると言うんですよ
もう試しに目を目を閉じて
自分の目の前にある何でもいいんだから見てください
目を閉じて目を開けて見た瞬間で
例えば私の場合だったらペットボトルやとわかるでしょうに
ペットボトルと思う 認識した瞬間でもうビタッカ考えてるんです
もう考えちゃったんです
なぜならば 花がレンガの建物だ
ペットボトルだと決めるためには
いろいろ考えなきゃ その結論には至りませんよ
品物は生まれつき名前を持ってますかね
持ってないんですよ 花は自分で名前を持って生まれるんですかね
そんなことないんです
これ 我々人間が名前をつけてるんだから
それに訳があるでしょう
花に花というわけがあるでしょう
そこは瞬時に出てきて判断して花だとする
それはビタッカということなんです
ビタッカしたものはジャンタキーと
すぐに とんでもないことをするんです
これも動詞なんですけど
パパンチャということをするんですよ
パパンチャカーにするんです
これは順番で確実に起こるんです
ディタクタっていうのは花だ
ペットボトルだ 建物だって思っただけなんですよ
それからごちゃごちゃ考えるんですよ
パパンチャというのはそういうこと
これ 勝手に自分でやってます
その時は欲やら怒りやら憎しみやら全部生まれてくるんです
パパンチャの中に それも各人によって違います
例えば このレンガの建物を見て
レンガかどうかはわかりませんだけど
この建物を見たら皆様に見えるでしょう
窓から見れば でもそれを見て何考えるかということは
それぞれ別々違うでしょうに
その考える時は必ずしも感情がついてくるんですよ
感情っていうのは欲か怒りか無知ですよ
そこでそれが私の知識だと思っちゃうんです
このパパンチャっていうのは
もう全くも訳できん 本当は無いものをあると思っちゃうんです
幻想と私はいつでも訳する
現象というんですね ここで現象の世界が生まれるんですよ
だから現象と本当の状態からはものすごくかけ離れているんです
これから皆さんはちょっと自分の感覚器官をチェックしてみてください
何か見た瞬間で 例えば誰かの部屋に家に行ってカーテンを見たにしましょう
カーテンを見た瞬間でカーテンだということですが
それはディタクタなレベルで
それから何か自分の感情もこみ上げてきて
知識という変なものが生まれてくるんですよ
だから私はあんたこのカーテン見てどんな感想ですか？というと
自分のパパンチャを語るんですよ
現象したもの 自分で組み立てたもの
自分の心の中で作り上げたもの
だからこのカーテンは綺麗ですよ
綺麗 まあ色が綺麗ですけど
模様があまり好きじゃないんですよとかね
模様が綺麗ですけど 色が良くないんだよとかね
色も模様も綺麗ですけど
このカーテンちょっと薄すぎではないんですか？とかといろんなことを言う
それはその人の その人は薄すぎと思う
その人であって 部屋の人がもうなんで薄いカーテンかって
その人のパパンチャであって
そうやって見た実際に目に触れたものと何の関係もなく
心の中ですごいパパンチャというすごいなんか工場みたいな働きが生まれてくる
現象の世界 そこでパパンチャが繋げるんですよ
過去にも行く 現在のものにも行く
将来のものにも行く 過去と将来は存在しないんですよ
見たのはこの今の瞬間の建物なんですけど
それにする頭の中の思考は
過去にも行ったり あらゆる現在の建物にも行ったり
将来的な建物にまで行くかもしれません
瞬時にすごい世界が心の中で生まれちゃうんです
それから我々は実際の世界からものすごくかけ離れているんです
見た瞬間で そのものからもう離れているんです
聞いた瞬間で そのものから離れているんです
離れて自分の世界に入っているんです
だから本当に情報に触れるんですよ
触れた瞬間で別世界を作る
別世界そこで自分の世界の中でごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃと限りなく回転する
限りなく回転するということは
過去現在 未来に渡って回転させる
そこで人間が偉そうに喋りますよ
何喋ってもパパンチャを喋ってます
だから何の意味もないんです
あの建物はもうちょっと高い方がいいなとかね
もうちょっと低くなった方がいいなとか
自分の主観の世界ですよ
この色はもうちょっと別な色と合わせた方がいいんではないかとかね
こういうことで人間がサムダーチャラントという会話するコミュニケーションをとって
自分でも考えたり 生き方していますけど
この人間のコミュニケーションやら会話や生き方ってすべてパパンチャのからくりなんです
本当の世界ではありません
だからなんですよ 我々はお互いに別々な世界に生きているというような
自分の主観の世界に生きている
自分の世界しか知りません
人のことだから知りません
人は何考えているんでしょうかと
知らないんだから喧嘩にもなる
このカーテンはすごい気持ち悪いと言ったら
その家 部屋の住んでいる人が気持ち悪くなるんですよ
その本人が好きだから買ってつけたカーテンでしょうに
部屋に来た人が あ これが気持ち悪いんだそうと言ったら
こちらもすごく気持ち悪くなっちゃうんですよ
それで喧嘩になる 物分かりいろんなことになる
例えば来た人がデザイナーとしましょう
インテリアのデザイナーだと言っちゃうと
向こうに対してこちらの主観でなんか向こうが偉くて
自分がその能力がないんだからコンプレックス持っちゃうんですよ
プロに対してあんた知ってるんだよ
それでインテリアデザイナーにやっぱりこのカーテンがちょっと感じが悪い
あなたの好みはちょっと疑いですよと言われると
ずっと落ち込んじゃうんですよ
そういうふうに我々は精神的にすごく苦しんでいるんです
すべてパパンチャの働きなんです
ですから 私は冗談でいい加減に言ったわけじゃないんですよ
もう我々 あんた方は見てないんだよとかね
聞いてないんだよというのは
その論理なんです 和田さんがフグは食べたことはないんだというのは
誰でも目があるんだけど
見てないんですよ あのインパクトを知って
インパクトについて妄想する
だからパパンチャというのは妄想としたってもいいんです
だからヴィパッサナーと妄想が別々しているんですよ
ヴィパッサナーは考えちゃう
そこは瞬時に起こる 目を開けたら花っていう瞬間で決める瞬間で考えてるんですよ
そこまではいいんですよ
別にいろいろデータ集めてみて
比べてみて 頭の中で瞬時に光の速度より瞬時に早く目を開けたら花と決まってるんです
それにはかなりデータ
集めてないと だから恐ろしい速さでやっています
その瞬間に あ これはバラの花
私はあんまり好きじゃないとかね
痩せっぽいの花ではないか
痩せているのではないか
枯れているのではないかとかね
なんかこの色はちょっとね
もうちょっと生き生きした色だったらいいんではないかというふうに考える世界が妄想なんです
それそういうふうに考えるためには
自分の好み 好き嫌い それは関係あるんですよ
この花の色はなんか枯れ
なんかもう薄れてあってね
あんまり良くないと言ったら
自分が好きじゃないという感情が入っているんでしょう
もっと生き生きした花だったらよかったのにと思っちゃうと
自分の欲が入っている
そうやって貪瞋痴で妄想するんです
それはパパンチャの世界
すべての生命がパパンチャの世界に生きているんです
それからは逃げられません
それでブッダがこのパパンチャを破るニッパパンチャの世界を言ってるんです
ニッパパンチャの世界っていうのは涅槃の世界
解脱の世界 見なさいよ
インパクト見るんじゃなくて
こういう風に厳密にセットができているんだから
訓練しないと難しいんですよ
これが今軽々く言ったんですけど
これはものすごい難しいことなんです
だからこういう言葉 単語を覚えておいて
この順番で何回何回も一人で一人で考えて考えて考えるよりも
実験して実験していかないと
実験してみてください
自分が例えば猫を飼っているんだったら
すごいかわいい猫を飼っているんだったら
ちょっと目を閉じてパッと猫を見る
見た瞬間で猫やってことはわかるでしょ？すぐにこみ上げてくるでしょ
ああ かわいいとかね なんて綺麗に寝ているんでしょうかとかね
そこがパパンチャの世界
それで自分がそれが確実正しいやと
この猫がかわいいんだと思ってるでしょ
そこで自分の友達が来る
猫嫌いな人が見ると ああ
嫌だと言っちゃうでしょ
それはその人のパパンチャで
実際にあの生き物が別に誰かに好きになってほしいやと嫌いになって
そんな関係ないんですけど
その生き物は自分のパパンチャの中に生きているだけなんですけど
それで私のペットだいぶ命より大事だ
私のもうもう子供やもう家族やと思ってる人にとって
ああ 嫌だ 私は嫌いだよと言ったところで
家に来た人がね その人は憎んじゃうんです
なんだこの人は失礼ではないか
それからその人に接するときはすごく嫌な気持ちで
できれば何か一言葉言いたいんですよ
いじめてやりたい気持ちがあるんですよ
それが普通の人間の生き方なんです
それをいろいろ実験してみてください
見栄を張って立派になることはなってやる
それはどうでもいいんです
見栄張らなくても ただ
パパンチャが生まれる過程
あらゆるところで実験してみてください
だから会社に行ったら
嫌な人がいるんだったら
その人を見た瞬間で 今のパパンチャからこみ上げてくるんです
嫌な人だ 気持ち悪いとかなんとかとかね
でも他の人はその人を見たところで同じ気持ちがこみ上げてくるかって
それは全く違う 自分の子供を見ると
もうなんて可愛いきれいないい子だなと思ったりするし
それで隣の人の子供となんで悪ガキ
もう本当にうるさいとか思ったりするし
すごいおかしいんですよ
病気と仏教はそれを病気やと言うんです
見てないんだと なんで自分の子は世界一可愛くて
隣の家の子がもう悪ガキですかね
そこら辺がこのパパンチャの世界というんですね
現象の世界 リアルな世界ではない
本物ではない しかし この本物でない
リアルでない 世界で我々は生きています
皆様 知識というのはそういうものに知識と言っているんです
そこでこのセットっていうのは
まあどうしようもない
これはこの獲物というかね
獲物の組み立て方はこんなもんなんですよ
本当は獲物っていうのは
これパパンチャのせいなんです
あの 見たもののせいじゃないんです
それで この誘惑について
あるところで仏教でこういう話があるんですよ
ある人が この世の中にはあまりにも誘惑がありすぎて
美しいものはありすぎて
この美しいものは欲だと私は思いますよ
それで仏教の答えは ナテーカーマーヤーニチトランローケ
この世の中にある美しいあらゆるものっていうのはカーマではありませんよと
サンカッパラがクリサッサカーマ
人の心にある概念が カーマです
欲ですよ 世の中にただ区別的にいろんなものがあるだけで
植物だったら葉っぱもあって
花もあって 実もあるという
それ区別だけのことなんですよ
色が違う 形違う 葉っぱの色と形が違う
花の色と形が違う 植物そのものの色と形が違う
それしか見えませんよ
だからそれが欲やと誘惑されちゃったんだと
花に言うのはおかしいんだけど
花が誘惑したわけじゃないんだと
あなたの気持ちが気持ちで花に釣られてしまったよと
花の奴隷になってしまったよ
だからすごい綺麗な人が見て頭がおかしくなっちゃった
もう好きになってしまった
恋してしまったと言っても
それはその人あまりにも綺麗だからよというのは嘘であって
でも大体そう言われるのみんな好きみたいんですよ
あなたはあまりにも綺麗だから
私はなんか頭がおかしくなっちゃったと言われてすごい機嫌がいいんですよ
そして本当はそんなに綺麗ですか？と
そんな嘘を言ったっても
実はそうじゃないんです
自分の妄想概念である人が綺麗に綺麗だと決めて決めるだけ
ですから 私がすごい美人でセクシーやと思う人が
他の人はそう思わないんです
だから欲って何なのかと
仏教から聞くと 仏教に聞くと
君の妄想であると 君の妄想そのものが君を誘惑されている
支配されている欲であると
外じゃないんです そういうわけで
仏教というのはすっごいものすごく難しいんですよ
いい加減で 神はてんと地が作ったんだぞとかね
初めは男作って それから女を作ったんだぞとかね
女を作るというか 材料がなくなっちゃって
男のあばら骨を 1本取ったんだぞとかね
そんな話ですごい普通
思ってる もうもういい加減ですからね
もうもうアラビアンの物語よりもレベルが低いんですけど
そんなものに乗り合っているんだから
もう乗ってるんだから
仏教はそういうとは随分レベルが違います
だから あなたの心の妄想で妄想がよこされては何だというふうなことじゃないんです
それはすごい計算して
厳密にお釈迦様の悟りた智慧で見ていってることなんです
本当は見てないんだと
外の世界 外の世界もろくに見てない人が
神は云々やとかね 永遠な天国って云々やとか
そんなの当てにするんですかね
そこをお釈迦様はそういうところはもう批判していますよ
みんな欲が良くないんだと偉そうに言うんだけど
欲って何なのかわかってないんだと
煩悩は良くないんだと
他の宗教の人々も言うんだけど
煩悩はどれぐらいあるかも最後わかってないんだと
執着は今日は読んだ経典であるんですよ
お釈迦様と喧嘩しちゃって
同じじゃないかと 私たちも執着を捨てろと言ってるんだよと
あなたも執着を捨てろと言ってるんではないかと
だからお釈迦様ではない
たら ちょっと待ってくださいと
君 執着はどれぐらいありますか？とお釈迦様は質問するんですよ
といったら答えられないんですよ
それで君はなんで執着が生まれるか知ってますかと
知らない ではどうすれば執着をなくせますか？知ってますかと
それも知らない でお釈迦様ももう出て行けっていう感じでね
で 比丘たちが喋るんですよ
世の中でそうやっていい加減なことを言うんですけどね
違いますよ みんなの観察能力ないんだと
だから執着を捨てろと言うだけで
執着がどれぐらいあるかわからないんだと
ある人は欲だけ執着を取っているんだと
残りつは言わない ５つありますからね
残りつは言わないんだと
ある人は欲と怒りだけ取っていて
残りは言わないんだと
知らないんだから 見てないんだから
ということでもうちょっと
反論はします まあ仏教の場合
やっぱり人間の思考っていうのはやっぱり攻撃
攻撃ではないんだけど
やっぱりもうそうやって言わないと仏教は成り立たないんです
全ての妄想 概念を壊して
人間の頭を綺麗に自由にする世界だからね
微かにでも依存は認めません
神にでもお守りにでも
親にでも誰にでも依存することは認めません
という点では かなり知識的に言えばすごいもうレベル高い世界ですけど
しかし勉強すれば誰でもわかるんです
誰でもしっかりした頭の持ってる人間になります
そういうわけで ある 今紹介した経典でも
ナテーカーマーヤーニチトラニローキ
世の中にあるものはカーマ欲ではありません
サンカッパラーガープリサッスカーマ
それだけでも覚えておいてください
えーと  これはもうよろしいですか
サンカッパラガー サンカッパっていうのはごちゃごちゃ考えることですよ
頭の中 ある妄想ですね
だから物が悪いんじゃないんですよ
我々の妄想が悪いんですよ
サンカッパラーガ 妄想自体がラーガで欲であると
プリサス 人間にとってまたカーマ
カーマ欲である 人の妄想概念が束縛される欲であるということなんです
それからこの前にまた戻りますけど
目があって形があって
感じて そこでインパクトが起きてとかね
それで妄想まで行っちゃう
そこら辺でそのシステムっていうのはあまりにも脆いんですよ
私たちはずっとやっていることは確かなんですよ
音が入った瞬間でも 音は聞くんじゃなくて
インパクトを知って それについて妄想する
目に何か入った瞬間で
そのインパクトを知って
ものを見るんじゃなくて
インパクトを知って それについて妄想するということは
もう光の速度よりはかなり速さでやってます
あまりにも早いんだから
我々は瞬間に起こると勘違いする
これ瞑想する人ってそこら辺がわかると思いますよ
音が入った瞬間で 音じゃなくてもうとっくに判断しているでしょう
どれぐらい早いと思いますかね
本当は順番で来るんですよ
音がする瞬間で カラスの声か車の音か
もうその瞬間でも判断している
それだけじゃなくて 時々もう感情も出てきて
妄想もしている パパンチャまで出ている
この速さっていうのはものすごいんです
その速さって 科学から科学者にはどう踏ん張っても見ることも知ることもできない
うん それそれ それはそれなんですけど
えらく脆いんですよ ちょっとしたことで壊れる
で そこでいうのは 例えば見るものがいくらあっても見えなかった
見なかったらどうなるんですか？ただ
目が閉じただけで あの強烈な妄想が消えちゃう
例えば何か見るともう楽しくてもうどうにもならんものがあるとします
目が開けたら あ 楽しくてどうにもならん
目を閉じてみなさい 閉じただけでも
あの強烈な感情なんでもいとも簡単に消えてしまう
それぐらい脆いもんです
だからこのセットでどちらが壊れたっても全部壊れてしまう
例えば目があります 開けて見ようとするんだけど
見るものがない場合は
あのパパンチャが出てこないんですよ
見るものがなかっただけでももう消えてしまう
あるいはもう一人の人が目も開けて目に情報も入る
入ったら見えた それで終わっちゃったらどうなりますか？このサンジャーの威嚇のところで
あ 見えた花 それで終わります
あ 見えた建物 それで思考をストップしたらどうなるんですか？何の欲も何の煩悩も何の主観も生まれなくなっちゃうんです
心すっごく穏やかになるんです
悟った人はそこら辺でストップするんですよ
パパンチャに行かない
これは大変に難しい仕事です
悟った人に煩悩がないということは
目が見えない 耳が聞こえないという意味じゃないんです
聞こえますよ 誰よりもものすごく鋭く
誰よりも鋭く見える だって見ているんだから
他の人は見ていないんだから
見えるんだけど パパンチャには持っていかない
だからお釈迦様やら悟った人々はみんなにもあんた知ってますこと教えてあげるんだから
まあテクニック...ノウハウでよろしいと思いますけど
で それで皆様理解してることでも
なんで別に見ることと聞くことにそんなにこだわらなくたってもいいんじゃないかということもあると思います
だから私は最初からもう魚の例を出して
これ餌ですよと 釣られますよと
釣られたということは
あらゆる苦しみが味わうこと
それが事実でしょうに
みんな楽じゃないでしょ
生きることは 人間関係でものすごい苦労してるでしょうに
自分の子供にしたっても
自分が産んだ子供なのに
その子供と付き合いっていうのは大変な難しいことでしょう
産んだ子供との付き合いさえも大変なのに
他の人々の付き合いっていうのはどれほど難しいかと
そういうふうに我々はえらく困っている
悩み 苦しみが生まれている
それであらゆるところに走り回っている
助けてくれ 助けてくれと
人々は金に走る 権力に走る
神様に走る これ悩んでるんだからなんです
だから我々はもう散々やられているんですよ
だから眼耳鼻舌身意のこの刺激について
刺激三蔵っていうのは
これがすべての苦しみの問題の種だということ
だから私たちはもう恋人と別れだっても
恋人と喧嘩になっても
仕事をクビになったっても
もう何だかんでもすべてここから生まれるもんなんです
アダムとイブが神様を裏切ったんだから
我々苦しんでるわけじゃないんです
私たちの六根の眼耳鼻舌身意というところの問題なんです
だから この見ないで刺激だけを受けるということが
それが良くないんだと
それこそが問題だと たったそれが問題だよと言いたいんですね
だから ちょっと話の順番を変えて喋ってきたんです
これが仏教でもものすごい難しいところで
タバンチャの構成っていうのはね
でもこれで全てわかると思います